and i come from horso
i lived in warsaw and i was born there
i come from a family i had three
brothers and i was the only girl
my parents were living worse of all
their life they had four children
and i guess by the time we really
realized what's going to happen it was
too late we couldn't leave
so we were caught like millions of
others we were afraid
i was very afraid i remember i was very
afraid
what did you think about the unknown
frightened me i remember that
i was just petrified um
and this is what happened also they
didn't you know
the the germans um came in the whole
poland fell except for warsaw
and boy so they decided to take a stand
so at night they shelled the heavy
artillery and then in the daytime they
had the bombs flying all over it was
just
voiceover was very very destroyed but
somehow we managed you know we were
hiding in the basement and
a lot of people got killed and it i
think that they thought of a boy so like
three weeks
uh not quite maybe maybe three weeks and
they bombed the border
and they there was no electricity there
was no gas
and then the germans came in after the
initial
uh you know attack then we didn't have
any water
so we drank the water from the from the
visla i don't know there was the liver
we took the water out and they were
throwing in dead bodies and horses there
was a typhus epidemic and i remember my
father got very sick and my brother
they were very very young they had a
typhus
ah and the conditions were terrible but
slowly you know
uh the germans really uh people don't
realize they really did use uh
psychological
uh catchphrases to
to um so we didn't realize what
what what was going on or what's going
to happen but the beginning they
organized together
and they pushed all the people from the
small little towns they pushed us in and
about i don't know how many square
blocks and they built up walls around
the boys or ghetto
you watch them build a wall oh i watched
them build the walls and we watched
and we watched um you know
and we didn't have no choice at that
time was really
really too late but my two brothers my
two older brothers
you know they were very young and they
were very impetuous and they
um and they just wouldn't they couldn't
cope with the germans like
you know when you walked on the
sidewalks and a german walked by you had
to walk down
you couldn't walk on the same side and
they they attacked you without
provocation
and they were they just said i'm not
gonna take this i i'm not gonna let
anybody spit on me and
abuse me and i don't i'm sure you know
as other people have told you that paul
are divided in two
uh the russian took half of poland and
uh the germany took half
so my brothers decided that they're
going to go over on the
ocean side and they left why did they
didn't make that decision they made a
decision because they felt that they
wouldn't be able to
they wouldn't do what they didn't want
to be humiliated
they couldn't they couldn't stand it
they were very young people and you know
people when they were rebellious and i
said i'm not gonna
uh i'm gonna spit back oh i'm gonna hit
him back i'm not gonna take this
so we had a family conference and my
parents decided that maybe it would be
better if my two older brothers leave
when the germans start to attack russia
a lot of people went back to russia went
deep into russia and they didn't
i don't know why they didn't so they
stayed
maybe they wanted to come back and
reunite with the family or whatever
and then the russians the germans took
over and they they had to dig their own
graves and they got killed
and maybe they wanted to come back and
be close to you yes
i have the feeling that they did
and um i wish they wouldn't i wish they
would have gone back
because a lot of people did survive in
russia
what was happening to you
to me i was a very
very mature very sheltered little girl
and when the ball broke out i grew up
overnight
i just really did my parents
were not even 40 years old my mother my
father
they were young people and
my father went out one day to the drug
store
to get some medicine and never came back
never came back you know the germans
went out they they were all these
trucks around and they picked up people
and there was a blockade he called it
like a blockade
so he went out to the dark story he
never came back he went out in the
ghetto
in the ghetto was quiet you know when
there was a when we knew that the
germans are coming
we didn't go out on the streets but
nothing was happening and the rockstar
was like
from here to the end of the building did
anybody see him
no he never came back so we assumed that
you know
there was a lot of people they were
catching people like a dog catcher you
know when a dog catcher goes out and
catches dogs
anybody they so understood they picked
up so my father was picked up
but you don't know you didn't oh we know
we know he was a victim
did you did anyone witness it so yeah
the people told us that
he went out and he never came back and
then my mother and my younger brother
was left with myself
and my mother was very dependent on my
father she really was and she
she went to pieces when they took him
away she really
she didn't care she really didn't care
if she lived or no
so i really had to watch over her
because um
she kind of like resigned you know there
was a care of you and
you couldn't go out and she she didn't
care she
she just she really wanted to die
but um somehow i say i was able to
you know to watch over her and then we
needed papers working papers
i remember i went over to a german and i
said to him i give you a diamond link
give me papers for my for my mother i
get all the 15.
who would they do that i did he did give
me the papers
and you did buy a little time for for
them you know without papers you just
didn't
have a chance wherever i went i saw
people laying on the streets dying
like you see the kids in cambodia now
you see that when i look at those
pictures
you get such a pain wherever you saw you
saw just
uh agony in pain uh
some of the polish there was the ak the
polish um
resistance to to the germans they were
trying to
bring in some ammunition you had to pay
it in gold
so people got together and we got gold p
whatever we got and we paid
but was nothing very little very little
came
in some of them were honest some of them
were not honest
you had to pay in advance and they said
to him look we're going to deliver you
20 rifles or 20 revolvers
and you gave them the gold and some of
them came in and some of them didn't
it was just that we were at their mercy
and with the food the same thing
you said they smuggled it in through the
sewers yeah
were these sewers large enough for
people well it wasn't that large enough
but you know you managed you were able
to bring some stuff in
some people were hiding themselves in
the sewers too because later on
when the germans really set up that this
is 1943 i was taking
out i was living in the ghetto till 1943
may 9 may may 10th you know when the the
jewish war zone
uprising was i was taking out almost one
of the last
people from the verse together were you
fighting with arms uh we were fight you
know what we did
in the warsaw ghetto which is uh you
know a lot of people don't know and they
feel that
we weren't really very passive but if
you want to look at history and i'm sure
you know
enough that countries like france or
belgium or holland they went
in a few days the germans came and took
over the war together was holding up for
four weeks even poland
didn't hold up for four weeks we were
holding out for four weeks the germans
were really afraid to come into divorce
together
what we did is we when they
they came in with tanks and they decided
to liquidate the boys together
this was a 1943 passover
and we all were prepared a few people
left up at that time was maybe i would
say
you know in poland we had three million
jews living
and in warsaw i would say maybe a
million or maybe more i'm not
you know my memory is not that great but
i would say more than a million jews
lived in warsaw
and um by that time were maybe twenty
thousand people left but i'm talking in
1942 maybe 30.
and the germans decided to liquidate the
boys together and when they
came into the warsaw ghetto uh we didn't
have much ammunition so we told
them a lot of molotov cocktails on the
tanks
and a lot of germans got killed so what
we did we took away their ammunition
i was part of it somewhat not that
involved with it
i i had all my energies to to to just
keep my mother
and my border together but i lived in
the same house so there was a lot going
on and we also had nominations did you
see in your house
it was 18 i understand you see mila 18
what happened
is in 1939 when they bombed the warsaw
this building was bombed hollowed out in
the middle the bomb hit it
in the middle so the bunker was on the
bottom
and we were hiding up on the third floor
on the fourth floor
it was big you know also it was a big
city with big apartments
so what we did is we had to go up with a
rope to pull ourselves up to high there
but you couldn't get up there it was
completely you know what you know you
you understand what i'm saying the
little middle building was all around
the middle
of stairs there was no stairs so we had
to
in the bunker the resistance bank was on
mila 18
and they were on the bottom so we were
very involved with they were all young
people you know mother anilevich and the
other
bunch of people they were all living
there where was your mother now
this is another one which is very hard
you see my mother was with me in my
border
one day the germans came in this was at
the very end of the voice of ghetto
i want you to know my mother wasn't even
40 years old
neither was my father
but my mother was um the germans were
coming
and we had to pull ourselves up on that
roar but i told you in the building
and she couldn't make it so she went
into the bunker below with the
resistance it wasn't exact there were
several blankets we didn't make big
bunkers because we didn't want it if the
germans will come in
we should have not all the people should
be caught so we
we had like five different bunkers
downstairs
and we were hiding upstairs might be 50
50-60 people upstairs
my mother couldn't make the road because
the germans were coming very
rapidly and she was hiding downstairs
and after they left the germans i went
to look for her and she was gone
they came you know we were upstairs i
told you they came at a fire truck
and with a ladder they took us all down
so it was my brother myself
at that time i was mad my husband
and his sisters we were all hiding there
maybe 50 people 40 people 50 people
that's
all that was left uh and the bunker
downstairs
mordechai leveraged i guess a couple
days later
he wrapped himself around in a jewish
flag and he was burned right on the
ghetto
it was burning everything was burning
you couldn't stay there
they smoked us out people had to get out
from the houses we couldn't hide
and then not only on top of this after
the houses were burning
they came in and they demolished them so
even if you were hiding the people got
suffocated underneath
you said you were married i wasn't i got
married in the ghetto
why my father before he was taken away
uh he felt like i was very young he
wanted to protect me
you know a lot of people got mad and
together amazingly
everybody got married because you felt
well you're going to die anyway might as
well
you wanted to attach yourself to someone
you wanted to be
have some connections with somebody else
my father was afraid if something is
going to happen to him
i should have someone to help me to take
care of me
so i met i was 16 years old when i was
mad did your father pick out the young
man
uh you know he was interested he came in
to my father had a grocery store my
husband had a bakery
so he came in and he knew me and i would
have never made under ordinary
circumstances i don't think it would
ever happen
but uh my father felt look he was 10
years older than i am and he will take
care of me and
and we had it better because he wasn't
he
his father was in the back of the
business so you know people used to
bring down ming colt
diamond for a loaf of bread so he had
food
and my father felt that i'm going to be
well taken care of
if i marry him so i was married in the
ghetto
it sounds strange but a lot of people
might end the ghetto you'd be surprised
really
uh so i was with his family and my
brother we were together my mother was
taken a few days before and then they
took us all to my donek
your husband too my husband too myself
so but when we went to maidanic this was
just the most terrible
as much as i experienced bad things
after but this was they put us
in cattle cars and they pushed in i
don't know how many people but they
really wanted us to die
and
we were in this those wagons um
uh i don't know how many people were
there
but my brother died in my arms my
younger brother was
and my husband's two sisters
it was not enough oxygen for all those
people
and they kept us in the swaggins for
days they wanted us to die in the wagons
you know the kettle cars with very
little windows
how old was your brother maybe thirteen
he wasn't even by myself
so you know when my brother died my
nerves
i said to myself
i'm gonna live i must be the only one
survivor for my family i'm gonna live
i made up my mind that i'm gonna define
i'm not gonna give it
because he wants me to die i'm gonna
live
i'm gonna just be very very strong
and i went to my donut and this is the
interesting story
because when i came to my donek
and i went to they put me in a block
with 500 other women
somebody told me my mother is there
my mother was taken a few days before as
i told you
so i went to see her and you know my
mother was there
so it's like i lost her twice really
but she was very very
lost she was lost
she was very passive she was very lost
and you know they gave you uh one
portion of what and one portion of soup
for the day
and i my mother became very skinny and
she was very thin and she was
they you know lost there so i used to
bring my soup to her in my
and i just cut off a little piece of
bread and i said to her
you know somebody gave it to me eat it
and i used to give it to her and run out
because if she would say to me eat a
little bit i would eat
i was very hungry but i felt that she
needs it more than
you know i was younger she needs it more
than myself so
i used to give her the soup and run out
because i didn't want to be tempted that
i should eat with her
and she wasn't the ghetto for she was in
the camp at me for about maybe
six weeks two months
every few weeks they used to we select
you know have selections and
one day just before they took me to
auschwitz
i walked down with her and she went one
way and i went the other way and
i i had a friend which we were hiding
out in the ghetto together we were
childhood friends for many many years
she didn't let me she pulled me back i
said how can i let her go and she said
helen you're not going to help her
you know where she's going and i i i
stayed
then we i went to auschwitz they sent us
to our shoes
and i wasn't i was the only one left
from the whole family my husband was
separated from the beginning the man
went different
and uh in my dark one of my husband's
sister
was with me and she was such a strong
girl a beautiful young woman
maybe 25 26
and we slept on the same bunk and she
developed diarrhea and she was very very
cold
and she only wanted me to lay next to
her to warm her body but she
she just didn't feel anything she was
she had very like
i don't know what you call it dysentery
or something
it was just awful i had to lay next to
her because she was dying
and she said helen please stay next to
me you know warm me
and she was the last one she went to
she died in the bed she lied by an arms
just like my brother did
it wasn't a bed it was a bong for five
people
did it have a mattress the store and she
was laying there and she was
the smell was so awful i was dying but
she was so scared she was old that's all
she was crying i should stay with her
so i did i stayed till till she became
cold and stiff in my arms i remember
when i was in auschwitz
and at the block where i was there was a
girl who had a baby would you believe it
if i tell you this
she had a baby we were able to hide this
baby for months
we delivered the baby ourselves
i i don't know i mean tell us about this
i i i
you know i i i don't know i
i really cannot it's very hard
it's very hard to explain it to you it's
very hard to explain
we just did it what we had to do we did
our aim was to defy hitler
to do everything we can to live because
when you lived
this he wants us to die and we didn't
want it we didn't we didn't want to
oblige him this was our
way of fighting back in auschwitz
the day started four o'clock in the
morning four o'clock in the morning
you had to go outside stay five and a
half
the black was 500 people in one block
and the germans had a compulsion and
that's why they have such fantastic
records
had to be counted every single prisoner
to be counted every single day by name
or by number my number
ever blocked so many people they had to
come and count you
we used to stay for hours this is the
way they wore us down they wanted to
wear us down
and we used to huddle our bodies
together because
you know the bodies gave out some warmth
for hours we used to stay on those
uphills
and then after this the orchestra
started to play and we went to work
what do you mean the orchestra story oh
we had a well we had an orchestra coming
now
to start coming or going to boycott
orchestra when we were left you never
heard of that
what kind of music did they play german
marches who should march
do you remember them no i don't remember
them but i know
that we had an orchestra leaving the
poor work and we had an orchestra coming
home
who were who was the prisoners some of
whatever whoever played an instrument
had to you know uh they had an uh i
would say about 10 12 people in
orchestra leaving in the morning coming
if you heard any of these marches
now oh please uh
you know i would certainly recognize it
i'm not a museum musical lover but
i do things you don't forget sometimes
we snuck in a little bit of a jewish
melody too
uh some of the players but um i think a
lot of them
maybe were jewish women who played were
jewish melodies
some of them they you know they they
sometimes knock and i remember we used
to march
i remember one time we marched with the
germans
and when we marched they were germans
with dogs but the big
so if somebody runs away uh the dogs
was just terrible anyway uh we used to
think i remember what did we used to
think um
the germans didn't know it's a jewish
song but it had
they wanted only melodies which like you
know
add itself to a rhythm of walking
so me song
i don't remember right now but i
remember we used to sing that song a lot
when we were watching um
story study guys let's vague or some
other songs
you know they didn't know it was jewish
can you sing them no no i i i'm not good
with singing but
this was one of the boy the songs it's
on the story started guys
do you understand what it means no don't
tell no one that
this is you let's last march this is the
partisan song
they were like five or six girls who
were working in the pool bomb
where they put actually the ammunition
you know the the what they call the
powder
into the grenade so they were every day
searched from head to toe naked
and when they were going into work and
then they left work
but they were able to smuggle out some
of the pulver
how in the vagina
and the mouth we were able to smuggle
out some of the powder
the powder was in something in a capsule
very small capsule which will put
inserted into the grenade
so they they and then
we gave it to the man and we blew up one
crematorium
in auschwitz so i want you to know that
there was in the camp
in the concentration camp with german
surrounded with
really the impossible we did blew up we
did blow up one commentary
when the germans were looking to the
ruins of this crematorium
they were able to find the shells and
they saw it was from our factory
this was in 1944 at the very end of the
war
was you see i was liberated in auschwitz
i was liberated in 1945 in the january
1945 by the russians
so this was already the war was going
very bad for the germans
and they took the five girls or the six
girls who were working in this
ammunition factory
and they hung them as we're all
18 19 20 years ago girl
one of them was i told you i slept with
her in the same bunk
one sister was not working there but the
other one was
this was written up once in hadassah
magazine i had this article because i
i was carrying the story was so heavy
with me i just
i just never got it out of my mind was
so painful and the whole camp had too
much
and they were hanging there for three
days you know when i talk about it i
just have
such pain
you know sometimes at night
i lay and i can't believe what my eyes
have seen
i really cannot believe it you know i
wasn't an auschwitz whenever i got up in
the morning
the lines were unbelievable
the kids used to come in stay in line
waiting to be ground
whenever i used to get up in the morning
i said my god
how can god allow this the kids were
standing in line
they didn't know you see they what they
did they showed
when they went into the crematorium you
saw our camp
so they saw that people are working and
they were you know
like a camp going on so when the people
got off the boat the train
what they saw they saw our camp the
crematoriums were a little bit you know
like around the corner
there were lines every day there were
lines
of people and of kids they bought a
transform from hungary once
such little kids they were waiting there
i just wanted god should strike me dead
i couldn't
bail i have nightmares about those lines
after i was liberated um i was two years
in a sanatorium
for two years after the war can you
imagine so it's like was
five years out of my life i was never
young there were some doctors
russian doctors in czechoslovakia
doctors came in with the first you know
with the first font
and when i was examined he said to me
under normal circumstances
i don't know it's impossible it's just a
a medical miracle that you survived
but i told you i i really wanted to live
i said to myself i want to live one day
and be free and one day after the war
finished then i don't care because i
really didn't care if i lived i would
die because i knew
that for my whole family there's nobody
going to be there
did you find your husband again would
you believe it that my husband survived
so i put in a direct course i put in the
paper my name
and i was looking for family and he was
looking for for his brother
and somebody read it and he wrote to his
brother and also he thought i'm the
sister
and he got us together and then joe came
they didn't let them into france and i
was in the hospital i told jonas and i
told you
so he came to see me from czechoslovakia
smuggled in
to the border they didn't you know we
were starting laws
we didn't have any past but we were no
we didn't have any state we didn't
belong to anyone nobody wanted us
america didn't want to nobody except for
israel maybe
and also to israel you had to smuggle
you had to go on boats and i wasn't in
condition to do that
what did you say when you first saw your
husband again
what did you say i don't know it's um
you know
the man i married and the man he was
after the war wasn't
the same person and i'm sure i was not
the same person neither when i was at
16.
and later on uh but somehow we had a
need for each other because
he knew who i was he was the only person
who who knew you know you feel like
you come from nothing you are nothing
nobody knows you
it's it's a fair strange feeling
you need some contact some connection
and he was my connection
he was he knew who i was and i knew who
he was
and we stuck it out we met i don't know
how many years i don't know we're going
to be maybe 35
or whatever we had two children
and he's very different he copes
differently than i do
and we're here we're here to tell you
the story which is
i don't know i don't know if it was
worth it
i don't know if it was worth it because
you know when i was in concentration
camp and even after i said to myself you
know
after the war people will learn they
will know they will
they will see you know we will learn but
did we really learn anything
i don't know
you